bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne
la séance de questions cribles
thématiques elle est consacrée
aujourd'hui aux problèmes énergétiques
en france c'est frédéric lefebvre
secrétaire d'état chargé du commerce et
de l'artisanat qui vient répondre aux
questions des sénateurs parmi les thèmes
abordés cet après midi en séance il y
aura bien sûr à l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire française c'est alain fouché
sénateur ump de la vienne qui va
interpellé frédéric lefebvre sur ce
thème
une question qui intervient alors que
l'on a appris aujourd'hui que les élus
strasbourgeois et bien se prononcer en
faveur d'une fermeture de fessenheim la
plus ancienne centrale nucléaire de
france tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle à très bonne séance à tous
mines et si des améliorations seraient
nécessaires en france à la lumière des
enseignements tirés de l'accident de
fukushima
nous appuyons cette initiative et nous
resterons vigilants sur la transparence
et l'information due au public
ceci étant dit la mission telle que
définie par le gouvernement ne nous
satisfait pas sur trois points
premier point son objectif nous
demandons son objet plutôt son nous
demandons que l'audit porte sur toutes
les installations nucléaires y compris
et pas seulement prioritairement sur les
autres y compris les installations
militaires
deuxième point les exigences requises en
matière de sûreté ne saurait se limiter
aux cinq points énumérés d'autres
aspects doivent être envisagées comme le
vieillissement des matériels et des
installations et je suis
particulièrement sensible à cette
question au regard des inquiétudes
légitimes que suscite la doyenne des
centrales non loin de chez moi
la centrale de fessenheim mais surtout
au delà des garanties techniques nous
sommes attaché à l'aspect social et
managériale de la sûreté nucléaire
je veux parler de l'organisation du
travail du recours à la sous traitance
et des garanties sociales
les collectifs de travail et les
habitudes de coopération la transmission
des savoirs sont les fondements
de la culture de la sûreté dans une
entreprise troisième point
l'étude doit être conduite dans des
conditions garantissant la transparence
et la publication des résultats avec une
expertise contradictoire
elle doit être menée sur le terrain en
association étroite avec les
représentants des salariés et notamment
les chsct
monsieur le ministre nos concitoyens ont
le droit de savoir l'état le devoir de
les informer au regard de ces éléments
et de vous prêt à donner une traduction
concrète à nos propositions afin que
l'étude sur la sûreté concerne
l'ensemble des installations nucléaires
que l'aspect social ne soit pas éludé et
qu'elle associe de manière large les
représentants de la société civile et
ceux des travailleurs du secteur
concerné merci monsieur frédéric
lefebvre secrétaire d'état chargé du
commerce artisanat des petites et
moyennes entreprises du tourisme des
services des professions libérales et de
la consommation est la parole
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs d'abord vous
me permettrez madame didier de d'excusés
le ministre besson
car comme vous le savez il est
actuellement aux états unis pour
préparer le g8 sur le numérique et de
surcroît il aura l'occasion au cours de
ce déplacement de faire le point sur un
certain nombre de sujets liés aux
questions énergétiques donc sur la
question vous poser d'abord vous avez
raison il ya une exigence absolue de
transparence et de sécurité en matière
nucléaire
j'ai bien noté que vous vous félicitiez
que le gouvernement est annoncé par la
voix du premier ministre
quatre jours après l'accident de
fukushima le 15 mars
'l'annonce d'une revue critique des de
sûreté des centrales confié à l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire sur les risques
principaux l'inondation le séisme la
perte des alimentations électriques la
perte du refroidissement la gestion
opérationnelle aussi des situations
accidentelles
vous posez la question de
la transparence en réalité quand vous
posez la question des personnels et de
la société civile sur cette question
date respect de la transparence
le cahier des charges sera rendu public
de même que les résultats seront bien
évidemment rendu public de cet audit sur
l'ensemble des installations nucléaires
avec priorité aux centrales comme ça a
été d'ores et déjà dit par le le premier
ministre pour la question précise que
vous posez sur les installations
militaires
il va de soi qu évidemment la sûreté
nucléaire est un sujet là aussi
essentiel pour ministre de la défense et
qu'il veillera à ce que la l'ensemble
des installations soit vérifiée dans
leur sécurité
merci la parole d'un monsieur jean boyer
ah pardon j'ai la réplique a proposé à
madame evelyne didier même la présidente
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez fait
que dans vos propos que confirmer les
termes de la lettre que deux qui a été
la lettre de mission de la scène donc je
réitère mes questions vous avez confirmé
la transparence mais au fond nous
attendrons nous verrons moi je vous
confirme la question que je vous ai posé
à savoir la question de la transmission
la question de l'aspect social la
question de l'intégration qui font que
il y à un environnement qui favorise ou
non la sûreté dans une entreprise et
particulièrement dans le nucléaire
donc je considère que je n'ai pas eu
tout à fait de réponse mais j'imagine
que vous aurez l'occasion d'y revenir
monsieur le ministre
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
jean boyer pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
oui madame la présidente
che ministre permettez que je revienne
sur la gestion gouvernementale de la
filière photovoltaïque et les
dramatiques car car ce sont des milliers
de projets privés ou publics qui ont été
sacrifiés parce que le gouvernement n'a
pas eu l'objectivité de prévoir des
quotas
et des tarifs de rachat pour une durée
déterminée
il a changé les règles avec une
rétroactivité
monsieur le ministre inacceptable car
les projets et est basée sur des
conditions précises il n'y a sans esprit
polémique
il n'y a pas eu de respect des
engagements il fallait clarifier les
dimensions les objectifs je veux
particulièrement parler des petits
porteurs qui représente une réalité
incontournable de la france rurale qui
veut travailler produire avancé
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre il est
trop tard et dommages causés elle très
nombreux porteurs de cette filière sont
graves
il fallait certes et j'en suis conscient
réguler mais pas casser pas casser une
filière en changeant les règles en cours
de route j'ai dans mon département
monsieur le ministre
plusieurs dizaines d'agriculteurs qui à
linverse des investisseurs spéculatifs
nationaux ont établi des projets
d'installations photovoltaïques sur des
bâtiments agricoles avec les difficultés
du monde agricole
ces projets leur permettait un
complément de revenus nécessaires au
maintien de leur activité
plusieurs d'entre eux avaient déposé
leur projet dans les délais malgré les
baisses successives des tarifs de rachat
il avait continué démarche lourde et
coûteuse
plus de 10000 euros environ la plupart
de ces agriculteurs ont engagé toutes
leurs économies
aujourd'hui après l'arrêté du 12 mars
ils n'ont plus de nouvelles leurs
dossiers bien que complet sont toujours
dans une attente insoutenable monsieur
le ministre
ils savent qu'il fallait réguler mais
pas casser la filière de ce que de ceux
qui ont engagé des projets réfléchi
raisonnable j'en termine j'en termine
monsieur le ministre pour vous demander
que comptez vous faire pour ces
agriculteurs et aussi d'autres en plein
désarroi pour que disait un peu d'espoir
quelles priorités donnez-vous au
traitement de ces dossiers est assez
porteur qui sont devenus monsieur le
ministre je me permets d'insister parce
que nous sommes assaillis qui sont
devenus des victimes innocentes
merci monsieur le ministre frédéric
lefebvre merci madame la présidente
monsieur le sénateur vous avez
parfaitement raison de souligner que le
gouvernement à changer les règles en
cours d' encore en cours de jeu vous
avez raison mais il l'a fait pourquoi il
l'a fait parce que les objectifs qui
avaient été fixés par le grenelle ont
été très largement dépassé et que ses
objectifs qui avaient été fixés par le
grenelle très largement dépassé vous le
savez il pesé sur qui sur le
consommateur alors à l'issue d'une
concertation qui a été engagée depuis
cette suspension et vous avez raison de
vous soucier évidemment de tous ceux qui
se sont engagés et qui attendent
aujourd'hui de savoir quelle va être la
règle
à la suite de cette suspension il ya un
nouveau dispositif de soutien qui a été
présenté en mars dernier
ce nouveau projet dispositif de soutien
qui prévoit une cible de nouveaux
projets de 500 mégawatts par an pour les
prochaines années avec compte tenu des
projets entrés et en files d'attentes
avant la suspension des perspectives de
développement pour 2011 et 2012 qui
reste soutenue sont évalués entre 1000
et 1500 mégawatts par an soit davantage
que la quantité installée en 2009 et en
2010 la cible annuelle de 500 mégawatts
sera réexaminée au milieu de l'année
2012 elle pourra être revue à la hausse
jusqu'à 800 mégawatts et sur ces bases
les objectifs du grenelle de
l'environnement seront donc largement
dépassé par rapport à la cible initiale
pour les projets d'une puissance
supérieure à 100 kilowatts crête qui
sont ceux que vous mentionnez un
dispositif d'appel d'offres est en cours
de préparation
le cahier des charges va être travaillé
avec la filière dans les prochaines
semaines et évidemment vous avez raison
il sera indispensable de communiquer à
l'endroit
tous ceux qui attendent les conditions
d'exercice de nouveaux appels d'offres
les conditions qui seront arrêtées après
négociation avec la filière pour la
réplique messieurs voyez oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie je dirais simplement que dans
la vie quand on a eu un accident
j'en ai eu il ya quelques semaines on
doit tirer des enseignements de pas
faire le même parcours
un ses ministres je ne prétends pas
avoir de leçon à donner à personne mais
tirons ensemble des enseignements pour
l'avenir
en effet le prix de rachat que vous avez
fixé
alain jantes à l'injonction du biogaz
issu de la méthanisation semble
inférieur au coût de revient dans la
production d'électricité par biogaz
aujourd'hui il devrait donc être relevé
il me semble indispensable que le
gouvernement ne cherche pas à faire la
communication sur la réussite d'un
dispositif mais prennent en compte
monsieur le ministre
l'essentiel à savoir la garantie et la
pérennité des projets sur le ministre
al'approche de la parution du décret
précisant les modalités d'injonction et
les tarifs de rachat je vous remercie
très sincèrement il beaucoup de modestie
par avance de tirer les uns les
conclusions de la déception du
photovoltaïque tout le monde préférera
des tarifs raisonnables de rachat de
biogaz pourvu qu'ils soient au dessus du
coût de revient et surtout que leur
stabilité soit garanti merci monsieur le
ministre de m'avoir écouté
merci la parole est à monsieur françois
fortassin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
catastrophe nucléaire japonaise a
provoqué une vive inquiétude chez nos
concitoyens qui le sont d'ailleurs pas
rassurés en apprenant l'allongement de
la durée de vie des centrales nucléaires
et que la maintenance se soient confiés
aux soins à des sous traitants
et du coup les énergies renouvelables
ont été remises au goût du jour un
consensus existe de nombreux états pour
préparer l'avenir énergétique
cela est bon mais est-ce parfois ce
développement de ces énergies se fait au
détriment de la logique du bon sens on
veut imposer un mode pour ne pas dire
une mode en matière de production
énergétique écologique
s'agissant de l'éthanol et de la
biomasse je m'inquiète des répercussions
que cela pourrait avoir sur la
production alimentaire
certes le brésil est un pays qui a de
vastes espaces où leur production est
satisfaisante
il en va pas de main dans nos pays
européens concernant la plupart des
énergies renouvelables elles ne peuvent
être stockées et par là même le peuvent
être produites que dans des moments où
on ne sont pas le plus utile concernant
l'éolien intellectuellement intéressant
cette production d'énergie à partir de
la force du vent est loin d'être
satisfaisante dans beaucoup de
circonstances
quand il fait très chaud ou très froid
il y à de hautes pressions il n'y a pas
de vent ça ne fonctionne pas quand on a
des vents violents
ça ne fonctionne pas non plus parce
qu'il faut arrêter les éoliennes elles
sont certainement très judicieuse dans
les régions en bordure de mer parce que
il y aura incontestablement des vents
réguliers
ce n'est pas le cas dans toutes les
régions françaises alors de plus il en
va exactement demain pour le
photovoltaïque poupe parce que là encore
ça fonctionne toute l'année mais
beaucoup plus en été alors que les
besoins sont surtout au coeur de l'hiver
le bilan n'est donc plus plus que mitigé
ne faudrait-il d'ailleurs pas interdire
les équipements au sol alors que de
vastes surfaces de toitures notamment
les bâtiments agricoles les bâtiments
industriels ou encore les toutous les
parkings très vaste qu'il ya autour des
grandes surfaces et des entrepôts qui
pourraient être couverts est destiné à
recevoir des équipements appropriés
l'énergie hydraulique est
incontestablement celle qui présente le
plus intérêt mais c'est souvent des
investissements très lourds et enfin n'y
aurait-il pas renié
nécessité à avoir d'abord une économie
d'énergie et le pot c'est celle qu'on ne
dépense pas en quelque sorte et ne
pourrait-on pas ce propos faire en sorte
de rendre obligatoire l'isolation
thermique de tous les logements destinés
à la location
voilà monsieur le ministre je voulais
vous poser la question suivante à savoir
quelle politique le gouvernement entend
il menait dans les quinze ans à venir et
qu'elles pour développer les nouvelles
énergies alternatives et de ce côté là y
at il véritablement un avenir que le
gouvernement peut nous garantir sur les
15 à l'avenir merci monsieur le ministre
frédéric lefebvre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur fortassin vous soulignez dans
votre question un des inconvénients
majeurs de l'éolien et du photovoltaïque
puisqu'il s'agit de leur caractère
intermittent l'électricité produite par
ces deux filières dépend en effet
fortement des conditions météorologiques
parfois décorés les à la demande en
électricité
d'autres sources d'énergie renouvelables
permettent toutefois de produire une
électricité non intermittente à partir
du biogaz d'énergie hydraulique ou
géothermique ces filières existent
d'ores et déjà dans notre pays ont
vocation à développer plus fortement en
particulier le tarif d'achat de
l'électricité produite à partir de
biogaz sera revalorisée avant la fin du
mois pour accompagner l'essor de la
filière méthanisation
malgré tout il est aujourd'hui ni
possible ni souhaitable que notre
système électrique repose exclusivement
sur les énergies renouvelables pour
fonctionner correctement le système doit
en effet disposer de moyens de
production
la puissance garantie d'une part de
moyens de production de base c'est notre
parc nucléaire
d'autres pas moyen de production de semi
base et de points plus flexible il
s'agit principalement moyens de
production hydraulique mais également de
moyens de production thermique gaz et
fioul afin de répondre instantanément
aux évolutions de la demande électrique
par exemple lors des pics de
consommation le
soit à 19 heures l'hiver par exemple les
énergies renouvelables permet de
diversifier ce bouquet énergétique vous
demandiez quelle est la stratégie
en voilà un certain nombre d'éléments
elle contribue ces énergies
renouvelables à décarbonés notre
électricité à développer des filières
industrielles françaises qui ont
vocation à rayonner à l'international
je pense par exemple à l'éolien offshore
sur lequel vous savez le président de la
république a annoncé un certain nombre
de décisions importantes
un appel d'offres de 3000 mégawatts de
capacité installée doit être lancée en
mai prochain sur un certain nombre de
sites dans notre pays vous avez évoqué
et anneaux les biocarburants le risque
de conflits alimentaire existe c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement met désormais
le cap sur ceux de la deuxième
génération qui ne sont pas en
concurrence avec l'alimentation et pour
finir sur l'isolation thermique la
nouvelle réglementation thermique pour
les bâtiments est paru en 2011 pour
application en 2012
elle fixe un objectif qui est très
ambitieux 50 kilowattheures par mètre
carré par an voilà quelques éléments je
crois précis qui répondre monsieur le
sénateur à votre question
un mode réplique monsieur fortassin un
mot tu es avec attention monsieur le
ministre et son discours incantatoire de
grande qualité sur le plan sémantique
pour autant je ne suis pas extrêmement
convaincu car je cherche vainement les
lignes directrices le biogaz très bien
mais est-ce que quelqu'un ici peut me
dire ce que sera la production de biogaz
dans une dizaine d'années
quels seront les objectifs ensuite pour
me dire qu'effectivement l'hydraulique
répond par sa souplesse à un certain
nombre de d'exigence cela nous le
savions déjà
et à partir de là jouets jeux c'est très
agréable d'être ici mais j'aurais pu à
la limite me dispose nous dispenser de
poser la question
la parole est à monsieur alain fouché
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je me réjouis que ceux des
barrettes été mise en place car
l'accident nucléaire intervenu au japon
suscite des interrogations tout à fait
légitime pour les français je tenais à
rappeler que les règles relatives à la
sûreté des centrales nucléaires sont
différentes d'un pays à l'autre et
surtout elles ne sont pas les mêmes en
france au japon et aux etats unis aussi
la sûreté de l'exploitation du parc
nucléaire d'edf fait l'objet de nombreux
contrôles internes par et df et externe
par l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
des inspections seront menées sur les
sites de façon programmée ou inopinés
en 2010 plus de 400 contrôles ont été
réalisés suite à ces événements
dramatiques le gouvernement a demandé à
l'asn de réaliser une étude de la sûreté
des installations nucléaires françaises
au regard des principales causes de
l'accident en cours séisme risques
d'inondation perte des alimentations
électriques
ce dont nous nous réjouissons les
résultats de cet audit seront connus
d'ici la fin de l'année 2011 et pourront
conduire un plan d'action pour renforcer
la sûreté de ses installations
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le ministre
qu'il est urgent de surseoir à la mise
en place de la loi nome à l'arbitrage
sur le prix de l'accès régulier à
l'électricité nucléaire historique
vendue par edf à ses concurrents tant
que l'on ne connaîtra pas les charges
que cette entreprise aura à supporter
pour la mise en place rapide de ce plan
d'action monsieur le ministre frédéric
lefebvre merci madame la présidente
monsieur le sénateur alain fouché
la france a fait il ya un demi-siècle
choix du nucléaire pour la production
d'électricité
un choix indissociable d'une exigence
absolue en matière de sûreté nucléaire
et de transparence j'ai eu l'occasion
d'ailleurs de le dire tout à l'heure en
rappelant les décisions qui avaient été
prises après l'accident de fukushima le
l'audit de sûreté des réacteurs français
en complément des démarches de sûreté
déjà mises en oeuvre par les exploitants
nucléaires sous le contrôle de l'asn
sont connus de tous je ne vais pas
rappeler tous les points sur lequel il
porte vous savez parfaitement entendu
tout à l'heure quand j'ai rappelé chacun
des sujets sur lequel la vigilance doit
s'opérer
les audits seront menées de manière
ouverte transparente je les dis le
comité pour la transparence et
l'information sur la sécurité nucléaire
y contribuera
l'asn rendra ses premières conclusions à
la avant la fin de l'année 2011
cette exigence de sûreté ces travaux
évidemment vous avez parfaitement posé
le problème peuvent amener à se poser
des questions sur l'application ou non
de la loi nome mais la loi nome prévoit
compris l'électricité nucléaire vendue
par edf à ses concurrents
le prix de l'arenh permettra de couvrir
sur la durée les coûts de production de
cette électricité y compris les
investissements d'extension la durée de
vie et les coûts de démantèlement
il ya un audit qui est en cours il n'ya
donc aujourd'hui aucune raison de
suspendre cette loi eric besson a
d'ailleurs précisé hier qu'une réunion
sera organisée rapidement autour du
président de la république pour décider
des modalités d'application de la loi
compte tenu de cette situation
un mode réplique monsieur foucher oui
madame la présidente monsieur nommé nice
bon j'ai pas tout à fait d'accord avec
votre conclusion parce que je souhaite
effectivement qu'on y revienne mais je
pense qu'il serait bienvenu pour éviter
que nos installations nucléaires soit
l'objet de critiques infondées que vous
continuez à communiquer au mieux sur les
règles qui régissent la sûreté nucléaire
en france
son contrôle indépendant et surtout la
spécificité française du rehaussement
régulier du niveau d'exigence de sûreté
imposés par la réglementation aux
centrales existantes
il s'agit notamment d'expliquer les
modalités des visites décennales en
rappelant les principes qui régissent le
niveau d'exigence de sûreté appliquée
aux centrales nucléaires françaises
ainsi que son évolution dans le temps
en effet certains pays c'est le cas
notamment des états unis autorisent leur
centrale à fonctionner pour une certaine
durée trente ou quarante ans dans
certains cas pendant cette durée jusqu'à
60 ans
la condition qu'elle fait ce qu'ils se
fassent toujours aux exigences de sûreté
fixé lors de leur construction
al'inverse en france le contrôle
décennale réalisé par l'asn permet une
réévaluation des exigences autorisant ou
non les centrales à profil
l'exploitation pour une nouvelle période
de 10 ans je crois qu'il est important
de rappeler tout cela merci monsieur
roland courteau pour le groupe
socialiste
oui merci madame la présidente
avec la dernière augmentation survenu le
lendemain des élections cantonales
les tarifs gaz se sont envolés + 20 % à
90 et même + 55% depuis la privatisation
de gaz de france dans le même temps gdf
suez annonce un résultat net en hausse
de 4,6 milliards d'euros tandis que son
conseil d'administration a pris la
décision de proposer un dividende par
action en augmentation
heureux actionnaires mais malheureux
consommateurs je pense plus
particulièrement aux trois millions de
ménages qui sont aujourd'hui en
situation de très grande précarité
énergétique
je passe également trois cent mille
ménages qui durant cet hiver n'ont pu se
chauffer au total voilà un sacré coup de
canif au pouvoir d'achat y compris pour
celles et ceux qui ont investi dans les
économies d'énergie
fort heureusement les élections
présidentielles approchent miracles
des mesures sont annoncées mais trop
tard et trop peu suffisamment en fait le
gouvernement ne manque pas d'air et
l'hygiène le prix du gas après l'avoir
augmenté de 5%
quatre jours avant et il annonce une
révision de la formule de calcul du prix
du gaz
après l'avoir augmenté de 55% à 5 ans et
tout ça après avoir laissé au groupe
gazier toujours plus de lest pour
proposer les tarifs à la crue en fait en
fait le prix de l'énergie semble n'être
qu'une variable politiques d'ajustement
augmentation une fois les cantons dans
le passé promesses de baisses dans la
perspective des présidentielles
monsieur le ministre gdf suez a amélioré
ses résultats de 6,5 millions en un an
allez vous donc proposé une baisse des
tarifs alors nous avoir plus de
transparence dans les coûts
d'approvisionnement de gdf
allez-vous mettre le paquet en matière
d'économie d'énergie
bref que comptez vous faire contre la
précarité énergétique
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur je vous ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention et j'espère que vous allez
écouter ma réponse avec beaucoup
d'attention parce que sur les questions
de l'énergie et notamment sur la
question du gaz
vous savez vous avez parlé à juste titre
des tensions qui pouvait y avoir sur les
prix des matières premières vous avez
parlé à juste titre des tensions qui
pouvait y avoir sur les prix de
l'énergie
et c'est justement la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement n'est pas resté
inactif
alors vous nous dites c'est arrivé trop
tard enfin je vous rappelle notamment
que le tarif social du gaz
c'est cette majorité qui l'a créé il
n'existait pas avant
et il a été revalorisé le rabais a été
revalorisé de 20% par ce gouvernement
de la même façon que vous avez sans
doute oublié de le rappeler c'est pour
ça que je veux donner les éléments
précis la suspension de l'application de
la revalorisation en juillet 2011 pour
recalculer le dispositif
cette suspension elle permet d'éviter
une augmentation des factures de 80
euros
ça n'est pas rien j'ajoute que sur le
gaz pour vous savez comme c'est
difficile qui est un certain nombre de
françaises et de français qui souffrent
loin de moi l'idée de dire que tout va
bien mais il ya ceux qui critiquent en
permanence et il ya ceux qui agissent et
agir et agir
je ne dis pas que c'est ce qui est plus
facile mais en même temps vous savez
je crois que c'est ce qu'attendent nos
compatriotes j'ajoute que vous avez
spécifiquement mis en cause gdf suez et
je veux quand même vous rappeler que ce
n'est pas sur la branche énergie que gdf
suez dégage des résultats dans notre
pays j'ajoute enfin concernant le gaz
que l'application de la formule
tarifaire j'en ai dit un mot tout à
l'heure avec cette hausse qui était
normalement prévu deux sets et demi pour
cent en juillet c'était 80 euros
supplémentaires ce n'était pas
acceptable et si nous avons suspendu
l'application de cette formule pour
renégocier le contrat de service public
de gdf suez
c'est parce que nous voulons inscrire
dans la durée une réponse d'abord
conjoncturelles
le rabais est augmentée pour les plus
démunis et une réponse ensuite
structurelles se mettent autour de la
table pour trouver la bonne réponse sur
cette question d'énergie qui est une
question essentielle pour nos
compatriotes
j'aurais peut-être l'occasion d'ailleurs
de parler du carburant j'espère que vous
allez m'interroger aussi sur cette
question parce que l'énergie c'est 8 %
des dépenses des ménages une réplique
monsieur courteau oui madame la
présidente
oui le gouvernement salle découvrir
aujourd'hui que les fondamentaux de la
formule de calcul sont à revoir
ce n'est pourtant pas faute de le lui
avoir dit et redit il vous faudra
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre nous
tous veiller à ce que le nouveau
mécanisme ne consiste pas uniquement à
répercuter les hausses du prix du gaz
mais permettent aussi de répercuter les
baisses
par ailleurs plus de transparence sur la
réalité des coûts d'approvisionnement de
gdf suez ne gênerait pas quant aux
tarifs sociaux que vous avez évoqué le
système est à repenser
les deux tiers des personnes en droit 10
pétantes n'en bénéficient pas de même le
prix du baril peut certes pesé mais la
libéralisation ubuesque que vous avez
vous lu n'a pas fini de faire des
ravages en feng merci de geler les prix
du gaz en juillet j'ai bien dit un jeu
et les gens pourront ainsi se chauffer
fortement pendant tout l'été par un tout
l'été merci
monsieur le sénateur lefebvre madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
c'est un rozoy bellevalle petite commune
de 114 habitants de mon département de
l'aisne que les sociétés hess et
toréador ont l'ambition de démarrer la
partie axonaise d'un projet de
développement portant sur près de 800
kilomètres carrés d'exploitation d'huile
de schiste
l'huile de schiste mes chers collègues
est un hydrocarbure liquide non
conventionnels comme le gaz de schiste
que l'on obtient par l'emploi de la
technique diderot fracturation celle ci
est consommatrice d'importantes
quantités d'eau associé à des produits
chimiques provoquant d impact sérieux
par dissémination ceci dans les nappes
phréatiques comme cela d'ailleurs été
mis en évidence dans des exploitations
réalisées aux états unis et au canada
l'autorisation de recherche pour ce
permis dit de château thierry a été
délivré à mon sens dans une grande
opacité en septembre 2009 pour une durée
de cinq ans sans qu'aucune des communes
concernées n'étaient seulement informé
ni même consulté et encore moins
associée
je note cependant que c'est à la suite
d'une question écrite que j'ai posées
sur ce thème publié le 10 mars avec
réponse parue le 7 avril que soudain les
présidents et conseillers des sociétés
que j'ai précédemment cités se
manifestent auprès d'élus que je suis
pour évoquer le calendrier et la
technique utilisée
les populations mais aussi l'ensemble de
la représentation nationale s'inquiète à
juste titre des risques environnementaux
et en matière de santé publique
il suffit que de visionner
l'impressionnant documentaire gazland
pour s'en convaincre
hélas il n'est pas non plus nécessaire
démunir et ici les délibérations
décision motion veut arrêter est pris
par les collectivités concernées dans sa
réponse à ma question écrite le
ministère informe qu'après une réunion
avec les industriels concernés le 10
février dernier il a été décidé
conjointement je cite pour les huiles de
différer le forage des puits après la
remise du rapport d'étape et de
n'entreprendre aucune fracturation
hydraulique avant que les conclusions du
rapport final de la mission précités ne
soit tiré à l'heure où le prix du gaz du
fait entre autres de notre dépendance
vis-à-vis des pays fournisseurs est trop
élevé à l'heure où le prix du baril de
pétrole remonte sensiblement à ce que
l'on peut noter le litre de sans plomb
98 à près de 1 euro 80 il peut paraître
néanmoins légitime de s'intéresser à
l'exploitation de ces gaz et huiles de
non conventionnelles que la france tient
enfermés dans ces sous-sols et nous
pourrions agir efficacement et
durablement sur les prix de cette
énergie dont les besoins mondiaux vont
croissant à quelques jours de la
publication du rapport d'étape prévu ce
15 avril de la mission d'inspection du
conseil général de l'industrie de
l'énergie des technologies également du
conseil général de l'environnement et du
développement durable sur les
hydrocarbures de roche mère je souhaite
monsieur le ministre vous rassurer les
populations et les élus quant à la
totale transparence dont fera par le
gouvernement tant sur le potentiel
énergétique liée à ces réserves que sur
les techniques d'extraction les aspects
économiques sanitaires et
environnementaux merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur lefebvre les
hydrocarbures de gaz et huiles de
schiste sont piégés dans une roche
imperméable
il s'agit de produits dans
l'exploitation suppose des techniques
non conventionnelles pour stimuler la
roche
alors on parle de facturation
hydraulique pour désigner ces techniques
qui repose sur l'injection d'eau de
sable et de produits chimiques
vous vous êtes ému et vous l'avez
rappelé à l'occasion d'une question
écrite vous avez soulevé la position
qu'ils avaient été prises par le
gouvernement je veux quand même compte
tenu de la conclusion de votre question
puisque vous souligné l'intérêt qu'il y
a à étudier cette question dans le
détail pour voir si c'est une
opportunité ou pas vous rappeler
qu'effectivement à la différence des
états unis il n'y a pas aujourd'hui en
france ou en europe d'exploitation de
gaz de schiste
mais l'essor tout particulier qu'il a
eus aux états unis font que ce pays
n'est plus importateur de gaz naturel
donc évidemment que le gouvernement se
pose la question
ça me paraît la moindre des choses il
existe en revanche trois permis
d'exploration qui peuvent donner lieu à
des travaux d'exploration qui suscite
des interrogations vous l'avez très bien
dit c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu
le 4 février dernier la mise en place de
cette mission interministérielle pour
éclairer le gouvernement et les élus sur
l'ensemble des enjeux liés au gaz et
huiles de schiste
le rapport d'étape sera remis dans
quelques jours ça permettra d'y voir
plus clair
en parallèle la commission du
développement durable de l'assemblée
nationale a confié 2 mars un rapport
d'information aux députés
françois-michel gonnot et philippe
martin à l'occasion du lancement de la
mission le gouvernement a réuni le 10
février les industriels titulaires de
permis d'exploration qui on vous l'avait
évoqué accepté n'effectuer aucun forage
mettant en oeuvre des techniques non
conventionnelles mais il faut la
transparence vous avez raison ce
pourquoi le gouvernement a accepté la
demande d'un examen en procédure
accélérée de la proposition de loi qui a
été déposé à l'assemblée nationale par
christian jacob député de seine et marne
et la discussion aura lieu le 10 mai ces
débats permettront d'éclairer la
représentation nationale et permettront
de donner toute la transparence que vous
réclamiez à l'instant dans votre
question
une réplique monsieur le sénateur
lefebvre oui merci monsieur le ministre
pour cette réponse c'est semble
effectivement que la transparence soit
de mise plusieurs propositions de loi
des collègues députés et sénateurs vont
d'ailleurs sur le même sujet donc nous
serons attentifs aux différentes
conclusions merci merci monsieur raoul
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre la catastrophe de fukushima
soulève évidemment de nombreuses
interrogations sur notre politique
énergétique
celle-ci mériterait qu'on y consacre
plus que les trois quarts d'heure dédié
à cette séance de questions cribles aux
réponses quelque peu candide
car ce sont les fondements mêmes de
cette politique qu'il nous faut revoir
aujourd'hui
en effet la dérégulation du secteur
énergétique que ce soit pour
l'électricité ou le gaz met à mal notre
souveraineté puisqu'elle contribue au
désarmement énergétique de la france
notre indépendance nationale qui était
le centre de gravité de notre politique
énergétique n'est plus d'actualité
puisque l'état se défait de ses leviers
d'action et en particulier dans le cadre
de la loi nome ce alors même que le
drame que connaît le japon devrait
inciter le gouvernement actuel plus de
prudence
par ailleurs il est ingénue de croire
que nous pourrions avoir une politique
industrielle sans politique énergétique
est d'ailleurs la privatisation d'edf va
bien à contresens des défis actuels et à
venir
la politique énergétique garantissait
aux particuliers aux entreprises n est
qu une électricité 30% moins cher que
dans le reste de l'europe ce ne sera
plus le cas avec la dérégulation des
régulations en plus d'une augmentation
continue des loyers les ménages vont
donc avoir à faire face à celle de leurs
factures énergétiques comme ceci a été
évoqué tout à l'heure la décision de
fixer la reine un prix entre 38 et 42
euros par mégawatt va conforter cette
tendance
par ailleurs la catastrophe va induire
un coût supplémentaires découlant d'une
demande légitime de plus de sûreté des
centrales nucléaires
dès lors monsieur le ministre nous
souhaiterions savoir quelle est la part
du coût de la sûreté des centrales
nucléaires dans le coût total de
production
comment va-t-elle évoluer dans l'arène
et donc pour le consommateur
il faudrait donc pour le marc av avec
des réponses à ces questions surseoir à
l'application de la loi nome
peut-on conforter confié encore pardon
la sûreté la gestion des centrales
nucléaires à des du privé il ya des sous
traitants enfin quelle est la ligne
générale de votre politique énergétique
pour les années à venir
mais monsieur le ministre merci madame
la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur sur cette question
de l'énergie vous avez souhaité élargir
le débat
le pétrole c'est 45 % de la consommation
énergétique de la france 20 points de
moins qu'en 1973 80 % de la consommation
électrique est d'origine nucléaire
sortir du nucléaire ce serait multiplié
par deux le prix de notre électricité
pour le consommateur et j'imagine que ça
n'est pas évidemment ce que vous
entendiez proposé à travers la question
vous avez posé mais la france a
aujourd'hui largement diversifier son
mix énergétique
elle a réduit sa dépendance et l'énergie
vous avez raison de le souligner vous
l'avez en tout cas évoqué n'est pas un
secteur comme les autres c'est pour ça
que le gouvernement met en place une
régulation stricte avec des obligations
d'ailleurs européenne vous le savez la
loi nome
mais avec aussi les tarifs sociaux qui
sont des initiatives je vous rappelle
qu'ils ont été prises par cette majorité
qu'il n'avait pas été auparavant qu'ils
ne l'avaient pas été par le passé
or la reçut la sûreté ne peut être
isolée vous l'avez dit l'audit est en
cours mais je répond parfaitement
questions posées et vous aurez
l'occasion vous avez un avantage sur moi
c'est que vous vous pourrez à nouveau à
nouveau me répondre vous avez j'ai
apprécié cité voltaire à deux reprises
dans votre question
j'ai eu l'occasion d'ailleurs de dire
tout à l'heure à vos collègues à
l'assemblée que ce lapsus que j'ai pu
faire un mérite c'est que vous
souvenez peut-être que dans sa digue
c'est large estrade qu'il disait il n'ya
point de mal dans nos naissains bien or
le bien c'est que dans cet hémicycle
vous parlez de voltaire aujourd'hui dois
je vous rappeler que voltaire c'était la
tolérance la tolérance un carnet et je
pense que ça peut être utile à certains
à un moment où je le redis le
gouvernement et la majorité sont engagés
dans une politique en matière
énergétique qui à la fois préserve
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
et en même temps protège les
consommateurs les plus fragiles d'entre
eux avec les tarifs sociaux mais aussi
avec les décisions de suspension
notamment que j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure l'ensemble des consommateurs
monsieur raoult la mode réplique
monsieur le ministre m'a pas échappé que
zadig n'était pas l'anagramme da gaz et
donc simplement j'attends des réponses
concernant en particulier l'application
de la loi nome et en fonction du prix de
l'arenh et quelles étaient les
conséquences pour les consommateurs mais
aussi pour notre industrie je vous le
rappelle qui bénéficiaient certes d'un
avantage concurrentiel par rapport à nos
voisins et en particulier les électro
intensifs alors la deuxième question qui
était posée c'était celle de la sûreté
de nos centrales nucléaires
est-ce qu'on peut la confier à la fois
là la construction la gestion et à des
privés et à des sous traitants de nos
industriels même nationaliser sa pose
réellement des problèmes et vous devriez
tenir compte des expériences de tepco au
japon merci monsieur didier guillaume
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
savons vraiment la problématique de
l'énergie est au coeur de la réflexion
de notre société de nos concitoyens
l'immense mobilisation pour sommet de
copenhague
l'ensemble des associations tous nos
concitoyens étaient mobilisés pour dire
ensemble il faut lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
il faut limiter les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ce sommet de copenhague a
été une réussite citoyenne
ça a été un fiasco politique aujourd'hui
le prix du litre d'essence augmente de
plus en plus et monsieur le ministre non
nos concitoyens ne peuvent plus payer
des sommes aussi importantes pour ce
pour se déplacer comme ils ne peuvent
plus payer des sommes aussi importantes
pour les charges pour l'isolation de
leur de leur logement
les accidents pétroliers comme cela
s'est passé le golfe du mexique avec la
marée noire où les accidents nucléaires
freeman island tchernobyl fukushima nous
montre qu'il faut que la protection soit
la plus forte possible
et puis nos concitoyens sont intéressés
aussi l'immense mobilisation qu'il ya eu
contre les explorations et
l'exploitation du gaz de schiste a fait
reculer le gouvernement
et cette mobilisation a vraiment été
quelque chose de très important
aujourd'hui nous avons une priorité
c'est celle de réduire notre
consommation énergétique car la
meilleure d énergie est celle que l'on
ne consomme pas les énergies
renouvelables sont elles toujours une
priorité pour le gouvernement
où en est-on du grenelle de
l'environnement si l'on en croit les
déclarations des membres de la majorité
la question de tonnerre sur le
photovoltaïque est très forte la mise à
mal de beaucoup de porteurs de projets
alors que la part des énergies
renouvelables d'augmenter dans le
bouquet énergétique
qu'en est il aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre du nucléaire après fukushima
rien ne sera plus comme avant il ne faut
ni attiser les peurs ni est derrière tel
lobby le lobby anti où le lobby pro les
français sont échaudés on ne leur a pas
dit la vérité en 86 quand le nuage de
tchernobyl a fait demi-tour à la halle à
la frontière sur une nucléaire il est
nécessaire de s'affranchir d'une vision
simpliste et manichéenne
le nucléaire est l'une des solutions
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
il permet la réduction de gaz à effet de
serre par contre il ne tolère pas les
approximations et les incertitudes
oui il faudra que dans notre bouquet
énergétique la part du nucléaire diminue
au profit des énergies renouvelables
alors monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les orientations du
gouvernement sur notre mix énergétique
et êtes vous favorable un grand débat
sur l'énergie en france
il faut que l'ensemble de la société
s'emparent de ce débat pour l'avenir de
la planète merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur guillaume un débat un grand
débat sur l'énergie je crois que chaque
jour depuis des semaines et je pense que
tout ce que j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure
toutes les initiatives tant
parlementaires gouvernementales montrent
à quel point dans ce pays on débat et
c'est bien de la question d'énergie vous
avez évoqué copenhague les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en france sont
moindres que dans la plupart des pays
industrialisés grâce justement à ce mix
énergétique sur lequel vous avez bien
voulu terminer votre question pour ce
qui concerne du carburant
c'est une un des points que vous avez
soulevé dans votre question le
gouvernement gttv avec gt avec christine
lagarde
le 9 mars dernier sur le terrain pour
renforcer et annoncé des mesures sur le
contrôle et la transparence
l'observatoire des prix et des marges du
carburants et du fioul
ces nouveaux ce qui nous permet
d'ailleurs de voir que les
professionnels ont été ont strictement
respecté leurs engagements c'est-à-dire
de ne pas répercuter à la hausse
en tout cas toutes les augmentations qui
étaient les augmentations du brut
premièrement deuxièmement la
revalorisation de 4,6 pour cent du
barème kilométrique
c'est une décision que le gouvernement a
prises que le premier ministre a annoncé
que nous assumons qui est une mesure
ciblée en direction des français qui
travaillent et qui roulent 5 millions de
salariés
95 % d'entre eux sont modestes
puisqu'ils sont en dessous de la
deuxième tranche du barème de l'ir pp
six cent mille commerçants et artisans
500000 professions libérales
je crois qu'il est indispensable de
prendre ce type de mesures ciblées et le
fait qu'il ait une contribution qui
étaient décidés de 115 millions d'euros
des professionnels me paraît une mesure
à la fois juste et efficace
par ailleurs sur la question de la
rénovation thermique des logements
le programme habiter mieux de l'anah
cette contribution est porté à 250
millions d'euros
là aussi c'était une de vos questions
précises ça va permettre d'atteindre un
financement total de 1 milliard 35
millions d'euros plus trois cent mille
foyers précaires qui vont bénéficier de
cette mesure
et puis pour terminer et j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour répondre par là même à
monsieur un raul qui posait finalement
dans sa réponse à ma réponse la même
question que vous sur fukushima
mais je veux vous dire je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure au groupe communique ce qui
posait la question
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure au groupe
mp qui posait la question le
gouvernement l'a montré la réponse a été
immédiate
l'audit la transparence et la sécurité
c'est ce que nous devons à nos
concitoyens et nous serons au rendez
vous de la transparence
j'espère que les uns et les autres vous
serez au rendez vous de ce débat aussi
avec l'esprit de tolérance que
j'appelais de mes voeux tout à l'heure
monsieur guillaume hameau de répliques
monsieur le ministre
le grand débat que j'appelle que nous
appelons de nos voeux fait tout
simplement suite au fait que le sondage
de la semaine dernière indique que six
français sur dix sont mal informés de la
situation de l'énergie du nucléaire en
france et le débat ne doit pas être
confiné dans des cercles de gens qui
savent mais d'en être mis sur la place
publique avec les associations les élus
locaux les industriels areva et edf et
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui veulent
dire quelque chose au sujet et ma
question était la suivante ce débat
citoyen que nous appelons de nos voeux
il est là pour crédibiliser la démarche
du gouvernement
les français ne veulent plus de ces
discours manichéen dont on ne sait pas
si ces discours tiennent de la vérité ou
tiennent de l'enfumage est tout
simplement ce débat public servir et à
la crédibilité de l'ensemble des acteurs
et enfin la question précise sur quelle
vision avez-vous de notre bouquet
énergétique de notre mix énergétique
vous n'y avez pas répondu faut-il oui ou
non continuer dans le tout nucléaire
réduire la part du nucléaire faire
augmenter les énergies renouvelables je
pense que cette question là les citoyens
s'en saisiront dans les prochaines
échéances je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous allons suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 18 heures et se
poursuivra le soir avec l'ordre du jour
suivant
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui aux problèmes énergétiques
si vous souhaitez la revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr cet après-midi à
la séance se continue sur public sénat
car les sénateurs ont entamé aujourd'hui
en seconde lecture le projet de loi
immigration intégration et nationalité à
mes côtés pour en parler jacqueline
gourault bonjour sénatrice union
centriste de loir-et-cher
alors ce matin claude guéant ministre de
l'intérieur a confirmé qu'il voulait
réduire l'immigration légale c'est la
première fois depuis l'élection de
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 que ce thème est
abordé
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce n'est
pas le sujet de la loi dont nous
discutons mais naturellement c'est un
sujet très important et j'ai noté
d'ailleurs que la ministre madame
lagarde e10 est strictement le contraire
donc je pense que il va falloir que les
ministres accordent leurs violons mais
une immigration légale c'est une
immigration qui est contrôlé
quantitativement si je puis dire
et jusqu'à preuve du contraire pour
l'instant la france n'a pas pâti de
l'intégration de populations dans la
société française au contraire elles
sont et enrichit donc je pense qu'il va
falloir que le gouvernement réfléchisse
à ce qu'il veut
réellement en tout cas autant je crois
les français sont sensibles au fait
d'être un peu fermes sur le fait de
l'immigration ou contre l'immigration
illégale
autant je pense que les français sont
attachés à ce que la france soit la
patrie du droit du droit en général et
de l'accueil en particulier alors autre
annonce faite par claude guéant il
s'agit de la connaissance du français
il a indiqué avoir écrit au premier
ministre françois fillon pour que le
niveau d'exigence du niveau de
connaissances en français soit relevé
quand on demande une naturalisation est
ce que c'est une condition nécessaire
aujourd'hui cette bonne connaissance du
français pour obtenir la nationalité
française
d'abord tout ça c'est à peu près d effet
d'annonce parce que déjà moi je suis
maire je sais très bien de quoi il
s'agit quand il y à une demande de
nationalité ou une demande de carte de
séjour
eh bien vous avez l'obligation quand
vous êtes maire de recevoir celui qui
demande
et parmi les critères qui nous sont
demandés c'est l'appréciation si cette
personne parle le français et donc c'est
déjà quelque chose qui existe
alors après je dirais est ce que c'est
un critère d'intégration évidemment
quelqu'un qui parle français c'est plus
facile de s'intégrer rapidement mais en
même temps j'étais jury fois l'éloge
écoutez moi j'ai souvenir degré de
connaissance du français côté j'ai
souvenir
j'étais prof aussi dans ma vie
antérieure j'ai souvenir au moment des
boat people c'est à dire à la fin des
années 70 l'accueil dans l'école où
j'enseignais
d'un certain nombre d'enfants qui venait
du cambodge ou du vietnam
il ne parlait pas un mot de français
parce que les jeunes générations dans
cette danse qu'on appelait autrefois
l'indochine ne parle plus le français
les vieux oui mais plus les jeunes
cette capacité qu'ils avaient à
s'adapter à apprendre le français
en quelques mois et d'ailleurs à être
souvent les premiers de la classe montre
que ça ne peut pas être un critère je
dirais d'empêchement de devenir français
alors autre disposition sur laquelle les
sénateurs de la commission des lois dont
vous faites partie est revenu donc en
commission il s'agit est bien de
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française il y avait une disposition
votée par l'assemblée nationale qui
prévoyait que les jeunes nés en france
de parents étrangers devaient formuler
la demande à leur majorité pour obtenir
cette nationalité vous avez dénoncé une
remise en cause du droit du sol ce que
vous avez la crainte que cette
disposition soit retoquée en séance eh
bien j'espère que non et j'espère que le
gouvernement aura la sagesse de ne pas
revenir sur cette décision qu'a prise la
commission des lois
je veux dire c'est une tradition
française ça existe depuis 1889 dans
notre droit français et si on
interrogeait beaucoup de nos
responsables politiques qui sont eux
mêmes souvent venant de familles
italiennes hongroise pourquoi pas n'est
ce pas eh bien ils ont acquis la
nationalité française comme cela et je
trouve que ça serait absolument
incroyable de revenir sur quelque chose
qui ne pose aucun problème sur quelque
chose qui a permis
tout simplement à des enfants et des
jeunes qui sont nés en france et qui
vivent tout le temps en france de
devenir jeu comment dire naturellement
français une dernière question
jacqueline gourault il ya de nombreux
points de désaccord entre l'assemblée et
le sénat
à l'occasion de cette seconde lecture
notamment en ce qui concerne le droit au
séjour médical pour les étrangers la
procédure d'expulsion
est ce que vous pensez au final que ce
texte va pouvoir être potentiellement
votée par les centristes
on verra bien on verra on peut pas dire
avant n'est ce pas comment on va voter
simplement je voudrais à cette occasion
à cette constatation ou fait répondent
par je dirais une remarque qui est la
nécessité du pluralisme
parce que quand un parti laisse pas
contrôler tout dans une assemblée
mais on voit ce que ça donne aujourd'hui
c'est l'ump ça a été autrefois le ps ça
peut redevenir un autre parti demain
matin le système électoral quelques îles
effet fait qu'un parti peut avoir une
majorité absolue ce qui n'est pas le cas
au sénat et je crois que la démocratie
se porte mieux
la preuve en est des décisions beaucoup
plus équilibré que nous prenons ici
merci jacqueline gourault d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je vous propose
donc à présent de suivre le début de la
discussion générale qui s'est tenue au
sénat en début d'après midi très bonne
séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion